[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the jury for the murder trial of derek
shovin is filling up as the judge rules
it will move forward plus the jury will
now hear evidence of george floyd's
prior arrests how police body cam video
could impact the trial clearly there's a
cause of death issue here
in fact it is highly contested and we
look into the so-called army of
prosecutors verse 1 defense attorney but
is it as it appears you've got to be
lean and mean everything you need to
know about the derek chauvin trial on
this special edition of law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the jury is nearly complete for
the trial of derek shovin long crimes
kim johnson is in minneapolis for us and
has the latest on jury selection for the
first former officer charged with
murdering george floyd to stand trial
brian the trial of derrick chauvin will
stay in hennepin county and will start
on time judge peter cahill had denied
the defense's request to move this trial
outside of this county into a different
county in light of a highly publicized
announcement last week of a settlement
between the city of minneapolis and
george floyd's family judge cahill said
that he didn't think there was a place
in minnesota that hasn't been exposed to
extreme publicity the judge also denied
delaying the start of trial same
publicity would continue with or without
a delay another development the judge
approved a 13th juror she is a white
woman in her 50s is passionate about
homeless issues and affordable housing
but said she doesn't hold any resentment
for police's handling of homeless camp
encampments
here she is being questioned on police
interactions
would you go as far as to say that if
you
resist the police or don't cooperate
with the police and you get harmed as a
result you kind of get what you have
coming to you
i don't know it you know it depends on
the situation i don't
if you're not listening to what the
commands are
obviously something else needs to happen
to resolve the situation so i don't know
how far the steps would go
it would depend on what the situation is
because derek shoven is white and george
floyd was black the racial makeup of the
jury is getting a lot of attention seven
members of the jury are white six
identify as people of color eight women
make up the jury five are men and only
one juror left to go but no matter how
quickly this jury is formed judge cahill
has said over and over again that
opening statements the beginning of this
trial won't begin any earlier than march
29th brian
thanks kim joining us today is a famed
criminal defense attorney who's no
stranger to picking a jury in a high
profile case mark gary goes uh mark
let's say you're the defense attorney in
this case how do you feel about the 13
jurors so far and the fact that you're
only going to have two alternates
look i think so far um the
jury is set up as a hung jury i i don't
see a verdict in this case given what
i've seen so far now we the caveat to
that is we've lost a couple of jurors in
the the last week due to the
announcement of the 27 million dollar
settlement which i think irritated the
judge in this case and
the defense but so far the defense to my
mind
i don't think they ever expected to get
an acquittal and i think they're
engineering this case for a hung jury
and so far i think they're headed for
that in that direction i would agree
with you but let's bring in co-host
terry austin terry
some of the jurors uh the prosecutors
kept on were were shocking we just heard
one i'm thinking of the juror who said
uh like we just said if something goes
wrong because you don't comply then that
might be how life ends up for you what
did you make of that juror making it to
the to the panel
you know brian sometimes attorneys have
to accept jurors even if they express
opinions that are contrary to what your
client might want them to say so i think
you're referring to juror number nine
she's a working mom she agreed with the
statement that if you don't cooperate
with the police then if something
happens then you have yourself to blame
and clearly if you are the attorney
trying to prosecute chauvin or using
unnecessary force you may not want that
juror on the case because she might just
very well defend chovin's actions but i
think ultimately she said that the
criminal justice system is not perfect
and there's room for improvement so
maybe the prosecution decided to take a
chance in the hopes that she try to
improve the system by holding chovin
accountable for his actions mark i
totally get that i'm a practicing public
defender in brooklyn you never get the
juror the perfect juror you've always
sometimes got to settle with something
in between but both sides still had
peremptory challenges do you think
either should have maybe used one of
those challenges for a now seated juror
do you think one of them should have
been kicked out well following up on
what terry said it's really more jury
deselection but there is a there is a
what i would consider a more overriding
um analysis you have to do you there are
uh i always say or i used to say that
there are leaders and followers goats
and sheep
you have to understand who's going to
drive a verdict the verdict you can look
at each individual juror and you can
always second guess yourself but what
you need to is you want to keep on who's
going to be the person who drives your
verdict or the person who's going to
stand their ground that's what that's
infinitely more important in this case i
don't think the defense they'll never
admit it are expects they're not guilty
so what they're looking for are jurors
who are going to stand their ground it's
friday at three o'clock they've been
deliberating for three days and they're
not going to change their verdict just
because somebody says you have to come
back on monday i would agree mark and
we'll keep an eye on the jury selection
because still got one left still ahead
on law and crime daily more on that 27
million settlement that the george
floyd's family and other police
misconduct settlements like it
but first the judge said it wasn't
coming in but has now decided the jury
will see the 2019 arrest of
[Music]
the judge in the trial of derek chovin
deals a win to the defense by allowing
them to show the jury parts of an old
arrest of george floyd law and crime's
angel levy is here with why the jury
will see only parts of the video
yeah brian judge cahill had actually
ruled last year that this 2019 arrest
video was out but now he's decided that
the jurors could see portions of it that
could help them answer one of the
central questions in this case and that
is what caused the death of george floyd
keep your hands where i could conceal on
may 6 2019 minneapolis police pulled
over a car in which george floyd was a
passenger on may 25th 2020 the date of
mr floyd's death
there is a
a very similar
starting situation derek chovin's
attorneys have argued the similarities
are so striking that the jury should see
the video open your mouth
that's just one of the similarities you
can see pills in floyd's mouth and
screen grabs of the may 2020 arrest
video judge cahill has ruled the jury
will be allowed to see only portions of
that 2019 body camera footage what is
relevant in the may 6 2019 case that
goes to cause of death or medical
condition
is essentially
the video of the body worn camera would
be admissible from the time that the one
officer approaches
mr floyd on the passenger side of the
vehicle
the subsequent behavior
with regard to eating drugs or not judge
cahill says there are plenty of portions
of the may 2019 arrest that are not
admissible meaning it's improper for the
jury to see mr floyd's emotional
behavior
calling out for his mother
all that is not admissible during that
2019 arrest a paramedic treated george
floyd cahill ruled that the jury won't
see that video but that the paramedic
can testify about specific parts of her
interaction with george floyd the
paramedic can explain
her actions
in
recommending to mr floyd to go to the
hospital the state had objected to the
jury seeing any of that arrest video
claiming it was irrelevant because
floyd's death was caused by chauvin and
the other officers not the fentanyl
infloid system famed forensic
pathologist dr cyril wecht agrees with
that conclusion someone who is going to
die
from an overdose of fentanyl just like
with morphine or heroin
is not going to be
aggressive in a physical sense in a
vocal
verbal sense but ultimately the jury
will make that determination clearly
there's a cause of death issue here
in fact it is highly contested
now judge case hill also ruled that a
forensic psychiatrist hired by the
prosecution will not be allowed to
testify about george floyd's state of
mind in the minutes before he passed
away whether that has to do with him
suffering from a panic attack some sort
of claustrophobia or ptsd but the judge
said that the door if the defense opens
the door to that type of testimony the
issue could be revisited so that
psychiatrists could eventually be
allowed to testify in rebuttal if the
defense opens the door brian
thanks ange here to discuss the ruling
on the 2019 arrest is criminal defense
attorney mark garrigus and terry austin
mark
i'm not sure if this tactically helps
the defense both the rest show floyd
taking drugs
he only dies when a knee is pressed on
his neck for eight minutes or more
doesn't that suggest that the knee
killed him
i you know it's amazing that you would
say that because i've been talking to
people this morning and saying the exact
same thing uh i don't know that this is
kind of the old expression be careful
what you wish for he looks compliant he
to somebody who is disposed to
the defense i'm not sure this
necessarily helps
it gives you an argument and the one
thing that i would say is
remember there is a federal grand jury
behind this or lurking in the background
one of the biggest decisions that the
defense is going to have to make is do
we put chauvin on the stand this video
they may be calculating that this video
helps them
not have to put chauvin on the stand and
be able to make their defense argument
without him because remember if he takes
the stand and it's a hung jury the feds
can come in and indict him and use what
he says
exactly terry if the argument is that
floyd always does this when he's
arrested but shoving didn't know that
aren't we just putting chauvin's
character on trial
well yes and oftentimes when you know
you try to put in drug use you're trying
to show that the victim is to blame here
but what the judge is saying is he
thinks it's relevant because cause of
death and medical evidence are so
closely related here and it's such a
huge issue he thinks it should be
admitted i actually think that you know
it's not more probative i think it's
prejudicial and having said that i think
it's going to be very difficult to just
show part of this video because the
jury's going to want to know what
happened before that exactly
the judge said there's a way that jerry
could end up seeing the entire 2019
video can you explain
yeah the judge said if that forensic
psychiatrist does eventually end up
testifying about george floyd's state of
mind then the 2019 video the entire
video has to come in and then the
forensic psychiatrist would have to then
offer
his or her thoughts on that whole video
all right so this is just the initial
ruling but we'll see how this plays out
this 2019 arrest being played for the
jury coming up on law and crime daily a
behind the scenes look
welcome back the city of minneapolis is
agreeing to pay george floyd's family 27
million dollars to settle a wrongful
death case but as chief investigative
correspondent brian ross tells us that's
far from the only such a settlement that
the city council and other cities have
reached around the country
persons on their stomachs can't breathe
with pressure applied to their backs
as soon as suspects are handcuffed get
them off their stomachs
this video was produced by the new york
city police department in 2003
showing the dangers of the knee-to-neck
restraint technique
the video was widely circulated to
police departments around the country
including to minneapolis it really had a
simple message that as soon as a prone
suspect is handcuffed get him off his
jump
and yet it was still being used in
minneapolis by derrick shuttle
it was still being used in minneapolis
it's
still being used in cities around the
country reporter aj lego of minneapolis
tv station care 11 found the technique
has left a long trail of deaths we know
of at least 107 deaths that followed
prone restraint since 2010. there are
likely many more he
was
on the ground for
too long with his hand handcuffed with
his hands behind his back with too many
police officers on top of him and the
kir-11 report found that more than half
the deaths involve people battling
mental illness david smith committed no
crime but he battled mental illness and
his behavior at the downtown ymca in
2010 raised red flags for staff and the
police were called
it escalated to a struggle ending with
officers kneeling on david's back for
about four minutes his autopsy shows he
died due to mechanical asphyxia caused
by prone restraint
david's family thought police would
learn from his death when my brother
died
and we fought and fought to show how
dangerous this position was after david
smith died his family filed a lawsuit
they sued and in 2013 minneapolis paid
out one of the biggest police misconduct
lawsuit settlements at the time in the
city's history
and as part of that settlement
the city of minneapolis agreed to
require its sworn police officers every
one of them to undergo training on
positional asphyxia
and it turned out part of the training
was playing that nypd video showing the
dangers of the technique and the
importance of getting the suspect on his
side when george floyd died and you see
the cell phone video that's gone around
the world
you see some of them you can hear some
of the younger officers that have only
been on the job
asking hey should we get him on his side
hey should we roll him on his side
on the side
and officer chauvin who was a training
officer and the senior officer there
says no
so naturally when george floyd died
we began asking that question what
happened to that promised training and
that's
no small point it's likely going to be a
key piece of evidence
in the officer's murder trial that they
had been trained to get off the back of
someone after they had them
in custody
interesting take when we come back is
eric nelson
welcome back if you've been watching
jury selection and derek children's
trout you may have noticed the defense
appears to be outnumbered when it comes
to lawyers anjanet levy is here to tell
us why that might not necessarily be the
case
brian by our count the state has 11
prosecutors some of them working pro
bono on this case while the defense has
one attorney and his assistant but we
found out in this case that it turns out
the that appearances could be deceiving
so ma'am let's assume you and i were to
meet under much different circumstances
a party or some sort of social or
networking event whatever it may be
and i uh you and i have our first
conversation
what are a couple of things that i
learned about you during that casual
conversation derek shovens defense
attorney eric nelson works for one of
the largest law firms in minnesota but
each day he appears in court alone judge
cahill noted the imbalance between
prosecution and defense at the end of
court thursday the state has a lot of
lawyers on this case
who can sit outside this courtroom and
start grinding out things
mr nelson
does not he
does not have the same level of support
the comments came after special
prosecutor steve slicher claimed nelson
made an incorrect statement about a
press conference held by the city that
afternoon in which reporters pressed
city officials about their decision to
announce a civil settlement with george
floyd's family when jury selection for
chauvin's trial was underway the
prosecutor said nelson needed to put his
concerns in writing how many lawyers now
are admitted pro hoc bj
and are working for the state on this
case so far mr is it 10 12
i i don't have that number your honor
but i do know that the police federation
the union is funding
the defendant's defense that's not
exactly true the union for minneapolis
police officers the minneapolis police
federation is not footing the bill for
chauvin's defense but the legal defense
fund for a statewide organization the
minnesota police and peace officers
association is paying the bill so does
the prosecution have too many lawyers
the old phrase too many chefs spoil the
broth former federal prosecutor gene
rossi says the prosecution's army of
attorneys could be a recipe for disaster
when you have that you can't move with
alacrity you can't move with precision
because you have too many people in the
room trying to make a decision but
nelson isn't necessarily alone despite
appearances the head of the mppoa told
the associated press that nelson is one
of 12 lawyers in the union's rotation
and he is consulting with them and
experts the union uses
i contacted the minnesota attorney
general's office and asked why the
prosecution team needed so many lawyers
so far there's been no response brian
thanks aunt jeanette mark so nelson
isn't alone do you think him showing up
alone as a way to make this case look
like a david and goliath situation seems
like a smart move
it's a brilliant move i
if i do say so because i've done it
myself in fact i had a federal trial
about 12 years ago where i just planted
myself as the lone defense lawyer and
the prosecution u.s attorney's office
had four people on the other side i used
to call them the gang of four and they
finally after i kept calling him the
gang of four complained to the judge and
he said well you are a four what's your
problem
mark don't give away too many of your
secrets now terry with so many pro bono
prosecutors
does it seem like this could maybe help
chauvin by making him look like the
little guy here
you know that's a really good point
brian and maybe the prosecution should
only bring a couple of the you know
attorneys who are helping them instead
of bringing everybody in because even
the judge as you saw there noticed how
large that team was but i think more
important than the number of attorneys
is their character i think that eric
nelson has been genuine and that's
coming across to the jury and they
probably appreciate that absolutely be
sure to tune in to law and crime network
for gallaudet gamble coverage of derek
chauvin's trial we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you